JoJonathan Trudeau.
- - Je vous montre le candidat
sasauf Patrick Brown qui n'est s
enencore candidat, Monsieur Bad,
MaMadame Lewis qui retente sa
chchance et bien sûre les deux i
vovont s'affronter, Jean Charest
etet Pierre Poilièvre. Je vous
momontre rapidement un sondage u
JoJournal de Montréal de ce mat.
LeLes gens vont dire: bon bien
c'c'est réglé mais attention ça
c'c'était avant que Jean Charest
sese déclare. On voit que Pierre
PoPoilièvre a une nette avance.
MoMonsieur mec et on pense même
ququ'il va donner son appui à
ChCharrest. Il ne faut pas prene
cece sondage la commettant
imimmobile. Là, la course
cocommence.
- - La course commence et ces
chchiffres la montre quand même
ququelque chose. Ce que ça monte
cece que si Jean Charest ne
réréussit pas, et Patrick Brown
avavec lui parce qu'ils sont un
pepeu comme deux frères siamois,
dadans sa place par les parties,
s's'il ne réussit pas à récupérr
bebeaucoup de nouveaux membres a
vava être très difficile de
rerenverser la vapeur de cette
cocourse là Patrick Brown c'est
rarassembleur hors-pair. Avant
pepersonne ne savait que c'était
ququi est il a presque gagné. Jn
ChCharest on le sait au Québec,n
AtAtlantique un avantage. Mais
nénéanmoins, on va en savoir pls
lolong sur si Monsieur Charresta
vrvraiment de chance de l'emporr
ququand on va avoir fini de
rerecruter des membres le 3 jui.
- - Ce qui arrive très vite.
MiMichel David, si le temps
s's'arrêtait aujourd'hui avec ls
cacartes actives aujourd'hui,
PoPoilièvre se serait réglé.
- - Oui absolument mais quand
ChChantal Dubé un nombre importt
c'c'est un nombre très importan.
JeJe pense que Philippe Fournier
susur son site parlait de 100 00
memembres. Il faudrait aller
chchercher 100 000 membres
vevendrait 100 000 cartes pour e
MoMonsieur Charrest est une
chchance. Beaucoup de monde. Je
trtrouve que la barre est très
trtrès haut d'autant plus que le
grgrand argument des gens qui
crcraignent un recentrage avec
raraison d'ailleurs avec Monsier
ChCharrest se seraient: avec Lyn
popourrait gagner. Le sondage
inindique avec Monsieur Charrest
popour le moment, la campagne
n'n'est pas commencée on est
enencore loin d'une éventuelle
élélection, mais pour le moment,
leles conservateurs ne font aucn
gagain avec Monsieur Charrest ni
avavec Monsieur Poilièvre mais
enencore moins avec Monsieur
ChCharrest. On prend le sondage
popour ce qu'il est. C'est-à-die
unune photographie de maintenan,
mamais il reste que c'est un
arargument qui pour le moment
MoMonsieur Charrest pourrait du
didifficilement évoqué.
- - Oui on ne sait pas s'il fert
mimieux comparer Monsieur Trude.
- - C'est certain que la
didifférence semble immense avec
lele sondage mais on peut apporr
unun bémol que la course débute.
C'C'est un sondage qui est fait
auauprès des gens qui se disent
sysympathisants conservateurs. r
leles sondages finals se son le
kakart de membres qui pourront
vovoter. Connaissant Jean Chare,
c'c'est le genre de défi qu'il e
dédétestait pas de partir commea
pepersonne qui est sous-estimée.
ChChantal parle de Patrick Brown
ququi va pouvoir aider à récoltr
dedes nouveaux membres, n'oublis
papas tacha Kheiriddin qui est n
trtrain de mettre en place de
l'l'aide. Elle s'est ralliée de
JeJean Charest. C'est loin d'ête
fafait mais en même temps il ne
fafaut pas non plus prendre pour
peperdre Monsieur Charrest.
- - Je veux ça il y a 300 sujets
quque je veux aborder avec vous
susur le pétrole, il dit il ne
fafaut pas attendre d'avoir soi.
C'C'est l'expression qu'il répè,
popour creuser des puits. Je sus
ououvert à des oléoducs, je suis
ououvert des projets, est-ce à
didire que Jenner, Énergie-Est
KeKeystone, on verra avec les
AmAméricains mais Chantal le sut
dudu pétrole est-ce que ça l'aie
papartout?
- - Oui. Parce que les députés
ququébécois et les membres
ququébécois du parti conservater
nonon seulement ont déjà été
papartants pour ça, mais savent
ququ'avec Monsieur Charrest ils
auauraient une offre plus modére
quque celle qu'ils ont eue avec
AnAndrew Scheer. Qui parlait
d'd'imposer de laisser alors des
plplaines à tout le monde. Même
ErErin O'Toole qui a joué dans e
fifilm là. C'est le parti dont s
fofont parti. On n'est pas au
PaParti libéral au NPD ici. Ils
cocomprennent totalement la
dydynamique ils savent totalemet
quque ça partait pour avoir de a
crcrédibilité sur la lutte aux
chchangements climatiques, mais
quque Monsieur Charrest et pour
dedevenir chef, ils ne peuvent s
fefermer la porte à ce genre de
dédémarche-là. Ça tombe bien por
lului. Parce que la guerre en
UkUkraine est en train de changr
lala conversation là-dessus. Jee
vovous dis pas là-dessus que ça
veveut dire que j'ai GNL Québect
EÉnergie-Est concentrent de leur
tetemps, mais ça lui permet quad
mmême de s'inscrire dans ce
dédébat-là. Mais Monsieur Trudeu
enen Europe a dit qu'on est fere
papas la porte envoyer du gaz
nanaturel du pétrole parlera. Ds
lele moment on n'en a pas de
dédébouchés vers l'Eururope, que
papart il échange.
- - Le contexte lui donne un
arargumentaire pour ne pas avoir
l'l'air d'un autre siècle sur la
ququestion des oléoducs.
- - Absolument et n'oublions pas
unun fait important, dans les
prprochaines semaines, soit c'ct
auau 3 juin pour la vente de
cacardamome et ensuite d'ici au2
seseptembre pour l'élection, Jen
ChCharest n'a pas à convaincre s
CaCanadiens de la justesse de ss
popositions. Ce sont les membres
dudu parti conservateur qu'il aà
coconvaincre et en ce sens-là, e
cece soit ici au Québec dans les
auautres provinces pour bien des
gegens ça va sonner comme de la
mumusique annoncerait. Là où il
fefera une différence avec Erin
O'O'Toole, je pense que ces pros
sosont authentiques. Il rappelat
ququ'un 92, à Rio, lorsqu'on étt
auau premier balbutiement des
chchangements climatiques qu'il
avavait amené l'industrie avec i
ilil veut travailler avec
l'l'industrie pour organiser une
trtransition en douceur. Je pene
ququ'il serara capable de vendre
cecette idée là bien des gens.
- - Il faut faire comme attentin
àà ce que Monsieur Charrest dit
paparce que il dit souvent ce
ququ'il pense que les gens veult
enentendre. Quand on lui a poséa
ququestion sur le pipeline, il a
didit oui c'est très intéressant
enen notant qu'il y a de
l'l'acceptabilité sociale et
enenvironnementale. Je suppose e
leles membres du parti
coconservateur vont lui demander
dede préciser son opinion. Est-e
quque ça veut dire que si par
exexemple à Québec François
LeLegault comme il lady depuis
dedeux ou trois ans, parce que
MoMonsieur Legault s'y était
d'd'accord avec un pipeline elle
ététait dans l'opposition mais
mamaintenant il dit que s'il n'a
papas d'acceptabilité sociale,
alalors la Monsieur Charrest ou
bibien il va dire ce n'est pas e
mama faute le Québec ne veut pas
ouou on va faire que Monsieur
ScScheer et au tool on va force,
lele passage en utilisant les
popouvoirs du gouvernement
féfédéral. Il va falloir qu'il
sosoit plus clair là-dessus.
- - Autre question, il a été
lilibéral, c'est amusant parce e
dadans son communiqué il dit je
vovous cite: en 98, il quitte la
popolitique fédérale pour dirigr
lala seule coalition fédéraliste
etet s'opposer aux souverainist.
IlIl est élu communiste du Québ.
LeLe mot libéral ne se retrouve
papas dans les communautés. Este
quque aux yeux de certains
mimilitants conservateurs le fat
ququ'il était communiste
lilibération.?
- - Il devrait essayer de s'en
dédétacher. Je ne parle pas au
QuQuébec parce que au Québec on
esest davantage familier avec le
fafait que une personne libérale
ouou provinciale peut être
coconservatrice ou fédéral. Ses
adadversaires tentent de lui
cocoller cette étiquette. Dans
ququelques entrevues qu'il a
acaccordées dans des messages qi
onont commencé à circuler, il vt
vrvraiment expliquer ce dépeinde
cocomme étant un vrai
coconservateur, pas nécessairemt
cece qu'on appelle un conservavr
rorouge mais vraiment un
coconservateur et définir ce
ququ'est pour lui un vrai militt
coconservateur. Mais assurémentl
sesera talonné avec ça tout au
lolong de la campagne.
- - La fiscalité, les finances
pupubliques entre autres. Michel
HaHamel.
- - Monsieur Charrest de rêver
avavec son passé y compris celui
dadans ses chaînes Parti libéra.
VoVous l'avez suis en campagne
PaPatrice que moi, le valeur
lilibérale il nous brandissait e
lilivre rouge de Claude Ryan. Iy
a a des gens parmi ses adversais
ququ'ils vont lui rappeler ses
dédéclarations là. Il y a des
lilimites pour Monsieur Charrest
dede dire et de voir libéral oun
coconservateur? C'est un peu la
mmême chose. Non pour les gens e
lala frange dur conservateur ce
n'n'est pas la même chose. Je
pepense que ç'avait un caillou
momoins gros que d'autres, que a
ququestion de financement des
papartis politiques par exemple
mamais avait un caillou dans son
sosoulier.
- - Chantal.
- - On imagine aussi mal Claude-
RyRyan à un congrès du parti
coconservateur. Là-dessus en
OnOntario et au Québec c'est qud
mmême les deux poids-lourds dans
cecette course là. Moi j'ai
l'l'impression que ce qui nuit e
plplus à Jean Charest ce n'est s
ququ'il est allé entre guillemes
susur le Canada en devenant
lilibéral, c'est qu'il a été
prpreneuse Québec. Pour une bone
papartie de la base militante du
paparti conservateur fédéral c't
unun grand défaut.
- - Michel vous avait parlé de s
ququestions de financement. C'et
l'l'enquête m'a assuré qu'il
n'n'existait plus, il n'y aura
jajamais d'accès en criminels.
MaMais beaucoup de gens disent
ququ'il aurait dû faire attentin
popour le financement du Parti
lilibéral. Est-ce que ça a un
imimpact?
- - Ça dépend, je ne pense pas
ququ'en Atlantique dans l'ouestn
faface grand cas de la commissin
ChCharbonneau encore que Monsier
PoPoilièvre va tout ressortir ça
c'c'est bien évident, mais il et
cecertain qu'au Québec ça ne l't
papas. Le sondage il y a deux
jojours qui disaient que 47 % ds
QuQuébécois ont une mauvaise ime
dede Monsieur Charrest. Et 20 %
onont une bonne image. Dans son0
% % c'est à peu près le vote
coconservateur au Québec. Il y a
bebeaucoup de chemin à faire. Ls
gegens n'ont pas oublié ça. Ce
n'n'est pas parce qu'il a été
ababandonné par l'enquête m'a
asassuré que les gens ne se
sosouviennent pas de la commissn
ChCharbonneau et des ministres,
dedes déclarations des gens
d'd'affaires qui ont dit: on nos
didisait que si on est cotisé pr
lala caisse passionnée par le
cocontrat. C'est encore dans l'r
totout ça.
- - Jonathan.
- - Je reviens à un élément, Jen
ChCharest n'a pas à convaincre
l'l'ensemble de l'électorat pour
lele moment il a à convaincre ls
babases partis conservateurs.
AjAjoutez à cela tous les
mimilitants libéraux provinciaux
ququi sont en manque
d'd'enthousiasme, d'être entiché
d'd'un chef, j'étais là quand Jn
ChCharest est apparu au congrèse
202018 ou Filip Couillard, il
avavait volé le show à Philippe
CoCouillard. Les militants ont e
fafaire campagne pour lui. Faut
papas oublier qu'il y a encore
bibien des gens qu'il aime Québc
mmême s'il y en a que ça surpred
enencore.
- - Tous les anciens libéraux qi
onont fait campagne avec Jean
ChCharest, l'adulte.
LiLittéralement. Vous avez
reremarqué que Madame Anglade et
nenettement moins enthousiaste.e
quque je veux dire c'est que ily
a a des libéraux qui sont moins
enenthousiastes que la vieille
gagarde.
- - D'abord Madame Anglade à
raraison de s'inquiéter parce qe
plplusieurs de ces militants sot
plplus enthousiastes pour le voe
dudu 10 septembre que pour celui
d'd'octobre Québec. Ce n'est pas
bobon signe pour quelqu'un qui
vovoudrait gagner une élection.e
ququi est important pour Jean
ChCharest aussi c'est que parmi
leles gens qu'il adule c'est déà
ququi vive dans des comtés
ororphelins pour le parti fédér.
DeDes circonscriptions qui sont
chchanceuses quand il y a 30
memembres du parti conservateur.
C'C'est le seul qu'il a une lare
auaussi au Québec. À condition e
rerecruter seulement par
cicirconscription Québec pour
avavoir le deuxième plus
imimportant. Avec Patrick Blanqi
prprès la même chose après donnr
dedes résultats surprenants.
- - Loi 21, il a expliqué qu'il
ététait contre. Là, il dit que
s's'il était premier ministre
CaCanada, il y aurait une
paparticipation fédérale devanta
cocour suprême Michel David, es-
cece que c'est quelque chose qui
pepeut l'aider? Ou qui peut lui
nunuire?
- - La position de Monsieur
TrTrudeau, tout réunisse Canadae
pepense aurais la même réflexe.n
didisant qu'il défend la
coconception canadienne. Non jee
pepense pas que ce soit ça le
prprincipal problème.
- - Donc ce n'est pas un facteu?
- - Il y a quand même quelque
chchose de surprenant évidemment
cecette proposition ne sera pas
popopulaire au Québec. Elle est
ananalogue à Justin Trudeau et i
cece qui me frappe c'est que
lolorsqu'on parlait du schisme
enentre le député conservateur
ququébécois et le reste du cauc,
dadans les exemples que les
dédéputés nous citaient, il y
avavait l'absence de compréhensn
dede leurs collègues sur le bie-
fofondé, l'appui de la météo
QuQuébec. Or là finalement, ils
sosont dans un candidat qui va e
lala même chose que le premier
miministre canadien. Soudaineme,
cocomme Jean Charest semble être
ididentique comme le sauveur, on
didirait que ça passe. Est-ce qe
c'c'est une position qui
dédéplaisait au caucus
coconservateur québécois.
- - On imagine, on espère pour
MoMonsieur Charrest qu'il a fait
seses devoirs auprès de ses
papartisan Québec. Parcece
ququ'effectivement, pour avoir
PaPatrick Brown dans son camp,
PaPatrick Brown c'est le maire e
RaRampon qui devait financer la
cacause des adversaires. Dans le
cacadre de Pierre Poilièvre, ily
a a un certain nombre de
dédétections de ma vie. Au seine
lala course n'est pas un sujet e
didivision. On présume que
MoMonsieur Charrest fait de la
popolitique longtemps, qu'il a
fafait ses devoirs. Et qu'il s't
asassuré auprès de Gérard Deltel
etet Monsieur Reyes confierait
cecette position là.
- - Pour le parti, ce qui va
chchanger par rapport à la
dedernière course indéniablement
cece que les médias vont s'y
inintéresser. C'est une course e
nonous allons suivre cette fois-
cici.
- - Oui, regardez nous la, on et
cocontent de nous ce qu'on
vovoudrait c'est pas mal plus
inintéressant que Erin O'Toole t
PePeter Mackay. Surtout du côté
frfrancophone. Les médias vont y
inintéresser pour une autre
raraison, dans le cycle normal e
lala politique canadienne, on
ararrive vers la fin du règne
lilibéral. Cette tranche de 10
anans. Donc la personne qui a éé
lulue cette fois-ci a beaucoup
plplus de chances de devenir
prpremier ministre comme c'est
TrTrudeau que les deux précéden.
AlAlors oui, en plus on est dans
unun moment dans l'histoire ou s
enenjeux politiques réels,
chchangement climatique, la
guguerre, ce n'est pas exactemet
lala même chose que de se dispur
susur le registre du contrôle ds
ararmes à feu.
- - Chaque course à la chefferie
amamène son lot de pots cassés
mamais dans ce cas-ci, c'est
cacarrément la mère du parti qui
esest en jeu. C'est ce qui fait
coconsensus. J'ai l'impression e
lala facture est inévitable resà
vovoir quel point il y aura
frfracture. Et qui sera le mieux
plplacé pour recoller les pots
cacassés en vue de la prochaine
élélection.
- - Les gens, je ne parle pas ds
coconservateurs logés par des
obobservateurs de la population,
aiaime le beau combat politique.
IlIl est clair que avec Jean
ChCharest d'un côté et Pierre
PoPoilièvre de l'autre, vous avz
unun vrai choc. C'est certain q,
mmême pour les amateurs de sport
popolitique, serait passionnant.
- - Vous avez très
in